>>> PRESIDENT BIDEN MET TODAY
WITH FED CHAIRMAN JEROME POWELL
AND TREASURY SECRETARY JANET
YELLEN TO TALK ABOUT INFLATION
AS PRICES OF GAS AND FOOD AND
HOUSING CONTINUE TO SKYROCKET
AND VOTER SATISFACTION SINKS.
LAST HOUR I SPOKE TO THE CHAIR
OF THE WHITE HOUSE COUNCIL OF
ECONOMIC ADVISERS WHO SAYS THAT
THEY'RE OPTIMISTIC.
>> WHAT WE UNDERSTOOD ABOUT
INFLATION WAS THAT IT WAS TIED
TO THE PANDEMIC.
WE'RE STILL IN THE MIDST OF THE
PANDEMIC.
RUSSIA'S WAR ON UKRAINE DISABLED
NOT ONLY GAS PRICES AND FOOD
PRICES, AND DISRUPTED SUPPLY
CHAINS.
WE DIDN'T FORESEE DELTA AND
OMICRON.
THERE HAVE BEEN CHALLENGES THAT
HAVE DISRUPTED GETTING US BACK
TO EQUILIBRIUM THAT WOULD HELP
BRING DOWN THE PRICES.
>> A NEW POLL SHOWS 46% OF
AMERICANS THINK ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS ARE POOR AND THE
GOVERNMENT IS NOT DOING ENOUGH
TO FIGHT INFLATION.
JOINING US NOW IS ROBERT REISH,
NOW THE CHANCELLORS PROFESSOR OF
PUBLIC POLICY AT UC BERKELEY,
ALSO THE AUTHOR OF "THE SYSTEM,
WHO RIGGED IT, HOW WE FIXED IT,"
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
BEFORE WE GET TO HOW TO FIX IT
AND SOLUTIONS, LET'S TALK ABOUT
HOW WE GOT HERE.
THERE WERE VARIOUS TIMES DURING
2021 THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
TREASURY SECRETARY JANET YELLEN
AND THE HEAD OF THE FED JEROME
POWELL DOWN PLAYED INFLATION.
LET ME GIVE YOU ONE EXAMPLE FROM
JEROME POWELL.
>> I REALLY DO NOT EXPECT THAT
WE'LL BE IN A SITUATION WHERE
INFLATION RISES TO TROUBLING
LEVELS.
>> OKAY.
SO THAT WAS WRONG.
THAT WAS FEBRUARY OF 2021.
DID THEY MISS WARNING SIGNS?
>> WELL, IT'S EASY TO SAY IN
HINDSIGHT, ALISYN, THAT THEY
MISSED WARNING SIGNS, BUT I
THINK THE CONSENSUS AMONG
ECONOMISTS, PEOPLE WHO WERE
ANALYZING THE ECONOMY WAS THAT
ACTUALLY THE INFLATION WE SAW
BACK THEN, THREE, FOUR, FIVE
MONTHS AGO, WAS MOSTLY PENT UP
DEMAND FROM, YOU KNOW, YEARS OF
PANDEMIC COMBINED WITH SUPPLY
SHOCKS.
I MEAN, ALL AROUND THE WORLD.
THOSE ARE STILL BIG, BIG ISSUES,
AND THERE'S A GOOD REASON AND
GOOD REASON TO THINK THAT
INFLATION MAY HAVE PEAKED, MAY
BE COMING DOWN.
BUT UNDOUBTEDLY THEY WERE A
LITTLE BIT OPTIMISTIC.
>> SO THE PRESIDENT, HIS OP-ED
IN THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
TALKED ABOUT HIS THREE-POINT
PLAN, AND I SPOKE WITH CECILIA,
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IS THE
ACTION BEHIND THIS PLAN.
SHORT OF LEGISLATION AND THE
REALITY OF 60 VOTES TO PASS
ANYTHING, AND DEMOCRATS CHANGING
THE FILIBUSTER, BEYOND LET THE
FED HANDLE IT, HOW MUCH OF A
PLAN CAN A WHITE HOUSE ACTUALLY
EXECUTE TO SLOW INFLATION?
>> WELL, PROBABLY NOT ALL THAT
MUCH, VICTOR, BUT IF YOU LOOK AT
THE BIG OIL COMPANIES, FOR
EXAMPLE, EXXON MOBILE, NET
PROFITS OF $5 BILLION, DOUBLE A
YEAR AGO.
SHELL, THE BIGGEST PROFITS EVER,
CHEVRON, THE HIGHEST PROFITS IN
A DECADE, THESE OIL COMPANIES
ARE RAKING IT IN WHILE CONSUMERS
ARE PAYING MORE THAN EVER AT THE
PUMP.
I THINK THERE'S AN ARGUMENT FOR
THE WINDFALL PROFITS TAX ON THE
OIL COMPANIES AT THE VERY LEAST.
INCIDENTALLY, THAT'S WHAT THE
CONSERVATIVE GOVERNMENT IN
BRITAIN JUST INSTITUTED LAST
THURSDAY.
>> SO SECRETARY, WHAT'S MORE TO
BLAME, THE PENT UP DEMAND AND
ALL THE OTHER FACTORS FOR
INFLATION OR CORPORATE GREED AS
YOU'VE SPELLED OUT?
>> IT'S ALL OF THE ABOVE,
ALISYN.
I THINK IT IS PROBABLY MORE PENT
UP DEMAND AND SUPPLY SHOCKS, BUT
UNDOUBTEDLY, BIG CORPORATIONS
ARE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
INFLATION AS A COVER TO INCREASE
THEIR PROFITS, AND IT'S NOT JUST
OIL COMPANIES.
ALSO YOU HAVE FOOD COMPANIES.
THERE ARE FOUR MAJOR FOOD
PROCESSORS IN AMERICA, INCLUDING
TYSON FOODS.
THEY ARE MAKING HUGE RECORD
PROFITS AND WHAT ARE THEY DOING?
THEY'RE INCREASING THEIR PRICES.
THEY ARE SAYING, WELL, WE CAN'T
HELP IT BECAUSE OF INFLATION.
THEY CAN HELP IT.
THE REAL ISSUE FOR THEM, LIKE
THE OIL COMPANIES, IS THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE VERY MUCH
COMPETITION, AND WITHOUT MUCH
COMPETITION, THEY HAVE FREE
REIN
TO INCREASE THEIR PRICES.
>> WE HAVE HAD MEMBERS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION, I MENTIONED
CECILIA ROUSE, JARED BERNSTEIN,
THEY'RE AVAILABLE EVERYWHERE,
BUT THE POLLS SHOW THAT DESPITE
THE PR PUSH, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE DISSATISFIED, ONLY 14% SAY
THE ECONOMY IS GOOD OR
EXCELLENT.
46% SAY IT'S POOR.
IF GAS STAYS AT $4.60, HOW MUCH
CAN A PR PUSH ACCOMPLISH?
>> WELL, I THINK A PR PUSH
CANNOT ACCOMPLISH ALL THAT MUCH.
I MEAN, IT'S IMPORTANT THE
ADMINISTRATION GET ARGUMENTS OUT
THERE AND MAKE SURE PEOPLE KNOW
THAT JOB GROWTH HAS BEEN STEADY
AND INCREASING AND VERY GOOD.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION GET ALL OF THE
GOOD NEWS OUT THERE THAT IS
POSSIBLE, BUT IN THE END, THERE
IS NOT A HUGE AMOUNT THAT AN
ADMINISTRATION, ANY
ADMINISTRATION CAN DO, AND THIS
IS WHY I HAVE BEEN PUSHING A
WINDFALL PROFITS TAX, BECAUSE,
AGAIN, EVEN IF THE CONSERVATIVES
IN BRITAIN CAN PASS A WINDFALL
PROFITS TAX, AND OIL COMPANIES
ESPECIALLY, IT SEEMS TO ME IT'S
EGREGIOUS, IT'S OUTRAGEOUS, HOW
MUCH THEY ARE CHARGING WELL OVER
$4 A GALLON WHILE THEY ARE
MAKING RECORD PROFITS.
I MEAN, AN ADMINISTRATION SHOULD
BE, AND YOU KNOW, IT'S EASY TO
SAY THIS, I'M NOT IN THE
ADMINISTRATION, BUT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SHOULD BE
REACHING OUT TO REPUBLICANS
RIGHT NOW AND SAYING THIS IS
OUTRAGEOUS AND NO CONSUMERS
OUGHT TO BE PAYING THIS AMOUNT
OF MONEY WHILE THE OIL COMPANIES
RAKE IT IN AND THEREFORE PLEASE
JOIN US IN A WINDFALL PROFITS
TAX, AND WE WILL -- THEIR
RECEIPTS WILL BE DISTRIBUTED TO
PEOPLE WHO DESPERATELY NEED IT,
WHO ARE PAYING REALLY A HUGE
PERCENTAGE OF THEIR INCOMES FOR
GAS, AS SHOULD BE DISTRIBUTED
FOR OTHER THINGS LIKE FOOD.
>> DO YOU THINK THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WILL TAKE YOUR
ADVICE ON THAT TAX?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK SO, ALISYN.
ALTHOUGH MAYBE IT WILL.
I'M IMPRESSED BY THE FACT THAT
INFLATION IS AROUND THE WORLD.
THIS IS NOT JUST A UNITED STATES
PROBLEM, AND YOU HAVE VERY LARGE
COMPANIES THAT ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THIS INFLATION.
ALL OF THE WORLD, THE OIL
COMPANIES ARE KIND OF LEADING
THE PACK, AND IF YOU HAVE
COUNTRIES LIKE BRITAIN WHO ARE
INSTITUTING A WINDFALL PROFITS
TAX AND THEN USING THE MONEY TO
HELP CONSUMERS GET THROUGH ALL
OF THIS, WELL, THAT'